the Bible says the spirit realm is real
the spirit realm permeates the Earth
Earthly realm even though you may not
see them God can open your eyes to see
what you don't want because if God
removes the veil and you see you're
going to be see constant constantly
spirits around you both good and bad and
you won't be able to function so it's
the mercy of God that the spirit realm
is veiled from you because if the veil
is removed you're going to be seeing
spirits every and you can't function so
Praise Jesus he's veiled
you can you imagine the veils your moon
I'm here in the kitchen there Spirits
right in front of me spirits to the side
of me on top of me everywhere some good
some bad how the heck am I going to
function oh come on man can you just
leave the kitchen please I just want a
sandwich even Timmy doesn't want you
yeah you get my point that's if you
believe the Bible if you believe the
Bible and you should because it's the
word of the true God and the true God of
the Bible exists and that God says you
are surrounded
with Spirit beings like even Halal Homer
who won't call me to debate his fake
prophet he believes that Halal Homer
will tell you according to Islam every
Muslim has a k and a Jin attached to him
or her he'll tell you right
hello he'll tell
you I think he'll agree see he'll tell
you he agrees so
behind every Idol there's a demon
attached that will use that Idol to
infiltrate your life and ens snare you
so when you have an idol of Zeus it's
not that there's a god named Zeus
there's a demon who appears as Zeus to
confuse you to think that he is your god
Zeus you get
it do you understand
that because I'm about to blow you away
from revelation
Madonna you're going to get blown away
by what you're going about to read in
Revelation so I'm trying to pret I'm
going to answer the serpent okay so when
people tell you atheist say hey you're
an atheist because you deny existence of
the gods and goddess of Nations so I
just happened to deny one more God than
you do no no no no this is where you
catch the atheist say no who told you I
don't believe in the gods and goddesses
of the Nations that's where you're wrong
the gods and goddesses of the nations
are demons
satans either Satan or some other demon
or the host of them that appeared in
time and space appeared in visible form
appeared in human form empowered people
to do Supernatural Feats in order to
deceive them to worship them as their
gods and goddesses and they took on
different
identities so don't be stupid and deny
the existence of the gods and goddesses
when an atheist asks you no they do
exist but they are demons who appeared
as gods and goddesses to deceive people
to worship them instead of the true
God everyone got
that do you understand that because I'm
going to show you something from
Revelation okay let me show you some
Revelation this going to blow you away
Revelation 213 but we're going to read
12 and 13 Revelation 2: 12 and 13
Christians get ready to be blown away by
this Revelation from Jesus this is why I
want to encourage Catholics Orthodox
Copic Assyrian Church of these eat up
the Bible eat it up it
is a supernatural book from the true God
that will blow you away if you
understand it here read this get ready
to be blown away to say wow this truly
is the word of the almighty God this
book is Supernatural and it's proof and
of itself that the god of the Bible is
real read
this and to the angel of the church in
pergas notice a church in
pamas write these things saith he which
have the sharp sword with two edges
notice what our lord Jesus says I know
your Works thy works and where thou
dwellest even where Satan's seat is what
what do you mean Jesus Satan's Throne
was in pergamos at that time Satan was
living in pergamos
Satan himself was on Earth and his
residence was there yes and thou holdest
fast my name and has not denied my faith
even in the in those days wherein
Antipas was my antios was my faithful
martyr who was slain among you where
Satan
dwelleth
wow Jesus our lord says Satan was
actually living at a certain location on
Earth in pergamon
pergamin he was living there and
reigning from
there do you know
why you know why can I explain to you
why that place was a convenient place
for S to to
rain here Revelation 2113 again post it
so you can get
it one more time
let me show you I Know Thy works and
where thou dwellest even where Satan's
seed is you live where Satan lives can
you imagine living in a place where
Satan is among you his throne is there
and from your location he is influencing
the world from your physical
location and thou holdest fast my name
and has not denied my faith even in
those days where in Antipas was my
faithful martyr who was killed there my
martyr who loved me more than his life
who died for the the Lord Jesus who was
slain among you where Sint dwelleth does
anyone have an
idea why this place would be the
location where Satan would Reign from
and dwell
in thank you Jesus Christ is Lord I want
to kiss your head because they had the
Temple of Zeus and a huge statue of Zeus
and pergas became the capital of Emperor
worship you got it there was a temple to
Zeus and guys correct me I'm going by
memory with the Temple of Zeus there
would be a statue of Zeus right so
because there was a Temple of Zeus and a
statue of Zeus there guess where Satan
is reigning there because for all
intents and purposes this would strongly
suggest Zeus was none other than Satan
appearing as Zeus to deceive the Greeks
in worshiping
him and it was also the hot bed the hot
bed of Emperor worship where the emperor
is demanded to be worshiped as a Divine
being in human
form so does it make sense that since
there was a huge Temple or Temple for
Zeus and a statue of Zeus and guys
confirm there was a statue of Zeus right
when you have a temple for Zeus that'd
be a statue I don't want to misinform
may the Lord Jesus save me from error
right so there was a Temple of Zeus and
a statue of Zeus in
pergamum so what did Jesus say that
signified Satan was ruling there which
means there's a connection between Satan
and
Zeus you get
it so are you now Blown Away how the
Bible supernaturally describes the world
we live in
and tells us that these gods and
goddesses they're not fake they are
Spirit beings demons headed by Satan who
appear in human form Empower their
servants to do Supernatural Feats and
even have sex with some of their
devotees confusing them and receiving
them into thinking they're the gods and
goddesses that they are to turn to when
they RI they're demons and Satan
yep Bobby Collins Exodus 12:12 Bobby
Collins God said that he was going to
punish the gods of the Egyptians yes
Ahmed if you believe Genesis 62-4 those
sons of God were Spirit beings that had
sex with women confirmed by second Peter
and Jude but that's a dis that's a
discussion for another time Ahmed gani
let's just focus
here okay everyone got it now if you
believe the Bible and you believe what
you just read Satan hasn't left the
Earth but he has left pergamos if you
believe Jesus Christ Our Lord then you
must believe Satan will take residence
in some place on Earth where he will
then influence the world from that
location if you believe the Bible that
means somewhere on the earth Satan lives
and dwells personally there and he has
his throne there and from that sphere
he's influencing the world which tells
you Satan is not in Hell he's on
earth now the question is where is Satan
dwelling at where is his throne is it in
Mecca well remember this keep this in
mind wherever Satan will be
dwelling from that place he will be
impacting the world in order to deceive
the world to fold in and follow his
deception and
deceit I say somebody could make a
strong case that's
America because America is influencing
the world poisoning the world with its
filth which is why you saw such a
demonic Onslaught against this man
Donald Trump who could not be bought who
could not be paid off
all the powers of Darkness Rose against
him the entire media came together to
expose
him and by the way don't misquote me
Donald Trump is not my savior he's not
your savior he is not my my hero and my
deliverer Donald Trump like the rest
done immoral things he's imperfect but
what a breath of fresh air we had a
president who wasn't ashamed to mention
Jesus Christ as Lord a president wasn't
ashamed to say Merry Christmas and a
president who fought against
abortion as imperfect and morally is he
was an angel in comparison to the rest
of the dirt
bags
okay so now that said do we understand
now icons and Idol are used by the
spirit
realm to influence and impact the things
on earth so an icon and Idol has power
either has demonic power or Heavenly
power from God because God does use
physical objects physical items icons to
communicate blessings and Graces that is
biblical and yet sadly when I was steep
too much into protestantism I ignored
all
that Ephesians 612 Masha it says your
battle as against Thrones principalities
dominions and the Heavenly
realm Ephesians
6:12 again melancolia I don't know I
said I wouldn't be surprised it's
America but don't quote me on this you
know why Melania I'm not a Prophet I'm
not Apostle I didn't receive information
from the Lord in a dream or Vision but
I'm saying I wouldn't be surprised it's
America because America impacts the
world they say if America sneezes the
world gets if the I'm sorry if America
sneezes the world gets sick have you
heard that saying when America sneezes
the world gets sick because of its Major
Impact on the world America has
tentacles in every part of the world it
is influencing the
world and what does Satan want to do
influence the
world why do you see there was such a
rise to condemn this man for four years
of his term they wouldn't stop the
slander the accusation for the entire
four years all we heard is about Russia
and we heard about the
dossier distraction after distraction
after distraction after this man with a
vicious demonic hatred and menth
and Satan doesn't take resonance in some
tiny area that's
insignificant Satan wherever he is
living in from that place he's going to
make sure he's going to make a worldwide
impact from that place that
Center aren are you kidding me you think
America hasn't become pagan America has
become a post-christian
anti-bible
anti-christian
anti-god immoral Pagan
occultic Nation you kidding
me anyway that's me my opinion